big developments today with the migrant
Caravan amassing on our southern border
the AP reporting that Tijuana officials
now have arrested 34 migrants on charges
like drug possession public intoxication
resisting the police meanwhile an
activist judge in San Francisco
temporarily blocking the
administration's policy of denying
asylum to migrants who crossed the
border illegally with reaction South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham you know
it was interesting now that they were
saying that Republicans were only saying
this to scare people before the election
it's real ask the people of Tijuana that
say they feel like they have been
invaded but it's now here and I want to
get your reaction how do we handle this
well number one if it weren't Fox News
you would know that people in Tijuana
had a problem with this the people they
are pushing back hard so under our law
if you come here illegally you can still
seek asylum and once you make an asylum
application it takes months for it to
get through we wind up releasing you
into the country this is nuts so I'm
going to introduce legislation early in
the next Congress to make sure that if
you come here legally you can never
apply for asylum President Trump is
right to change his policy and we'll see
what happens
yeah all right let me turn to another I
have your statement on Saudi Arabia I
don't think there's been anyone in the
media more critical more regularly than
this for sure of Saudi Arabia how they
treat women gays lesbians Christians and
Jews are persecuted with that said I
believe MBS did know I'm probably
ordered the killing of this Jamarcus
Auggie here's the problem we have World
War Two we had to align with a mass
murderer by the name of Joseph Stalin to
defeat Hitler right we didn't like that
Alliance either right now we have a
historic moment where US Israel Egypt
Jordan the Emirates the Saudis are now
perfectly aligned against Iranian
hegemony and the threats of them getting
a nuclear weapon with their radical
ideology of wanting to destroy the world
in America and Israel all right I think
there should be as you I agree with you
about sanctions I agree there needs to
be a punishment mm-hmm but I also agree
with the president we should not end
this relationship yeah and I'm not
talking about ending the relationship
everything he said it's true about the
strategic nature nature of the
relationship but here's what I believe
sardine it Rabia needs us more than we
need them it's not too much to ask an
ally not to butcher a guy in a consulate
this is not world war two so I'm not
gonna look away at what MBS did I think
he did it I think he's absolutely crazy
about what he's done in the Mideast yes
so a dangerous Ari push him that yeah
into the arms he would buy it would have
more strategic alliances we drove him
into the arms of Putin Iran Syria and
China well I'll be honest with you Sean
there's no way Saudi Arabia evers gonna
line with Iran they're mortal enemies if
they like I got it the bottom line here
is I care about this critique
relationship I'm gonna support Israel
completely but I'm not gonna turn my
back on this guy we've got a historic
opportunity here tell the people in the
in the Mideast there's a new sheriff in
town if you disrespect us and you
trample over civilised norms you're
gonna pay a price if you want to keep
NBS that sure decision to make Saudi
Arabia as long as you make that decision
you have a hard time with me if you want
to replace him with somebody who's not
crazy that would be a good move yeah I
agree with you holy all right as it goes
it's not complicated for me I like Saudi
already good either this guy's crazy
needs to go but this guy I actually
really believe we have a moment in
history that never existed before this
strategic alliance colony actually
totally a hundred percent the moment
will - a peace in the Middle East and
the Iranian czar far too dangerous we
cannot allow that moment to come when
they have news let me ask you right now
radical Islam with a nuclear weapon is
really dangerous yeah that's a that's a
bad scenario AG what would you like to
see I don't really
mr. bars good I like mr. ludic there are
a lot of good choices I'd like to see
somebody in place next year that can
guide the Justice Department in a new
direction
I think Jeff Sessions had to go the
president was right to replace him I
like mr. Whittaker fine but I don't
think he's the permanent solution I
promise your viewers if I'm the chairman
of the Judiciary Committee we're gonna
find about find out about the FBI the
way they got a FISA warrant against
Carter Paige you can essentially pointed
yesterday good shoe were on the other
foot they would be crucifying us right
now if this was a warrant issued against
a Hillary Clinton sympathizer I mean I
cannot believe the double standard of
our friends in the media shoe on the
other foot this is somebody that you
know that hated Trump and we're going
after a Clinton person like this it'd be
front-page news all over the place -
let's we're not just a rule of law we're
gonna find out where it goes all right
how important is Mississippi and then I
gotta roll the Senate race if you care
about judges you care about tax cuts you
scare about a strong military vote for
the Republican the Democrats going to
take us back where the Republican to
keep us on track all right and thank you
for being with us Lindsey Graham how
about Happy Thanksgiving